welcome back Brendan Fraser's portrayal
of a morbidly obese recluse in the film
The Whale as zone of an Oscar nomination
he's spoken out about society's
treatment of overweight people calling
for the need to stop the bias against
those with obesity but an age where the
world is in the grip of any obesity
epidemic not least which in this country
is this whole notion of body positivity
making the problem worse I'm joined Now
by Great British menu star Tom Carriage
who famously lost 12 stone and looking
in magnificent shape you work out every
day you would just tell him I do I try
to work out every day in different
things so when I first lost a load of
weight it was through cardiovascular
stuff so I swam so I used to swim mile
every day how big were you at your beach
oh it's over 30 Stone 30 Stone yeah yeah
in that moment what was the trigger for
you actually saying I've really got to
do something about this age so there's a
point where you get to it so I was
approaching my 40th birthday and I think
that's always a point of reflection
isn't it I think when you get to 40 I
mean I know it's not that long ago a few
peers you get to that point where you
just think hey where where what have I
achieved what have I come to and where
am I going so I think I think there's a
point 40 if is is always a real kind of
a testing point for many people for me
it was okay what have I achieved what am
I doing career-wise it was all going
great the restaurants were fantastic the
pub was great the recognition was good
we were doing stuff on the Telly so
there was no there wasn't a health scare
which I'm sure there would have been at
some point there wasn't there was there
was no conversation we're mates of yours
or family or viewers whether it may be
were people making comments to you that
made you think you know what about your
weight about your size whether people
was that part of it as well no no no
none of it it was all self-conscious so
the thing about anything that you have
to do whether it's losing weight whether
it's an issue with addiction whether
it's giving up smoking whether it's
alcohol whether it's gambling whatever
it is whatever it's part of your life
none of us are stupid we all know it's
bad for you if you eat loads of Mars
Bars every day you know you're going to
be in a bad space if you drink too much
it's about self-responsibility so a lot
of it comes to you know what am I going
to do to change the bad my issue with
debate is it obesity rates we know are
just going through the roof all around
Europe actually but particularly in this
country where it's shocking uh and
America
um and I see people for example I
remember a while ago
a model in America she was a plus-sized
model called Tess holiday she appeared
on the cover of Cosmopolitan magazine
here she was over 300 pounds and about
five foot tall and there wasn't a single
word in the whole piece which did
anything other than celebrate her
supposed body positivity I felt that was
incredibly harmful in terms of making
people think this is actually a positive
thing that's morbid obesity that's going
to kill someone so I think the
positivity that's a mindset yes okay I
think if you are if you're morbidly
obese I mean the word morbid in front of
it is frightening and it's something
that you have to reflect on on yourself
but then at the same point but my foot
does fat shaming if you you know when I
when I put on a bit too much Timber I
can absolutely rely on one of my sons
they're all pretty fit or my brothers
who are not as fit actually but like to
doing it out
um what the first thing they'll do is is
say oh you put some Timber on right and
that will always make me go back to the
gym yeah in other words I believe that a
bit of fat shaming goes quite a long way
in making you think actually really okay
I better do something about it well not
all of us are in the same fortunate
position as you me and you where we can
go to a gym we have a gym that we can go
to that we remember running yeah but but
we all know that if if it's not
something that you actually enjoy doing
it's not something that you're going to
continue to do so the exercise that you
need to do the way that you can do it is
by finding something that you enjoy
doing if you if you just hope that
shaming is wrong
um yeah I think a lot of it's about
education a lot of it comes down to
poverty and if you think of the most the
majority of places where you'll find
that most people are morbidly obese are
places where they come from economically
challenged areas where the foods that
they can afford have done that process
right so a lot of it will come down to
food poverty so it's not necessarily
about eating too much it's about eating
the wrong foods and the problem with
those wrong foods have processed foods
that are saturated fat high in sugars
they lead to what you think is those
processed carbohydrates fill you up but
they don't last very long so you eat
more and you get into this very vicious
circle and that it's not about fresh
vegetables it's not about and that's
also a food education point if you save
up alcohol completely I did yeah I
stopped drinking how big a factor do you
think in your dramatic weight loss was
the just killing the booze oh massive
hello so I have an issue with alcohol so
my I that first and foremost that was a
big part of giving up and losing weight
was an issue with alcohol but also even
if you're a mild Drinker or someone who
just drinks at a weekend alcohol changes
your mindset so it does lead you to
going a lot of cheese on total or go for
that Curry or I'll have that Kebab no
question so it's not just about the Lost
calories or the weight that you could
put on from alcohol and the sugars that
are in it it's actually from the mindset
that changes and see I'm on a bit of a
health kick at the moment so I've had
barely any alcohol in five weeks eating
very healthily going to the gym two or
three times a week Peloton the other
days right and I'm getting quite fit
again as I've done sporadically but
there's always a moment when I'm gonna
hit that wall when I you just slightly
lose that Steely self-discipline Street
you came through that yeah and most
people don't what especially in July
January and so on what's your advice for
people to break in through the wall
there's a mindset and but it's very very
different when both me and you now are
in that point of middle age where you're
struggling every day and you're trying
to find that balance between everything
where if you're morbidly obese with the
point where I was well over 30 Stone
you're then at point that your life is
so unbalanced it's completely out of
control that one thing is you have to
unbalance it completely the other way so
you have to remove whether it's
carbohydrates or sugars or lower
calories and alcohol and you have to it
becomes unbalanced the other way if you
have a relatively balanced diet which
sounds like you have now when you go up
and down and you're you're kind of in
control of it like everybody else and
that's okay what you do is okay you know
but it is that point where you do find
yourself that you are overweight you
need to it is a structured mindset and
most of it does come down to finding
food but I would say the most
motivational thing in my life over the
years about losing weight was actually
reading Ali Ross's TV column in the sum
where this pasty face little
from Aberdeen would regularly torment me
for being fat now I thought he was right
so it made me get fit so I think there's
an example where being fat shamed
actually can help it just cuts through
all the crap does that works for you you
are too fat that works for you but
there's many people you don't know their
situations you don't know where they're
at you don't know why their mindset is
like that and the only way that you're
ever going to lose weight or you're only
going to do that is if you can do it
that's true you have to do it yourself
and somebody's telling you you already
know you're fat you I mean you have a
shower every day or a bath and you get
out and you see yourself in a mirror
right you know you know you're
overweight you could it's actually going
internally I'm seeing a lean mean
fighting machine exactly that six-pack
is shown and free thank you it is going
to be that point where you have to make
that decision and it can only come down
it doesn't matter how many people take
in fact that could probably make it
worse if you have some form of
insecurity and somebody's telling you
you know you come for eat if you're
comforting anyway and then you're
constantly getting told that it can only
lead to work so I'm gonna leave it there
I want to talk to you again another time
about Pub because I was brought up in a
pub yeah and I share your passion for
pubs and as a war on pubs as we know a
lot of them going under and so we'll do
another debate on that another time but
it's great to talk to you about this
it's a really big issue a lot of people
out there at the moment doing this dry
January don't be January so I'd rather
suit myself than do uh and you're a
prime example of how you can do it so
congratulations thank you again cheers